[Música]
bienvenidos al espacio de historia de
Franz 24 Mi nombre es Luis Muñoz la
Corte Interamericana de Derechos Humanos
hizo pública una sentencia histórica el
estado de Colombia fue condenado por un
plan de Exterminio contra la unión
patriótica se necesitaron 30 años de
litigios para esclarecer la
responsabilidad estatal en la muerte de
6000 integrantes de este partido de
izquierda un genocidio político
orquestado en convivencia con
paramilitares fuerzas armadas
narcotraficantes y empresarios crímenes
de lesa humanidad en las décadas más
sangrientas del conflicto colombiano
pero qué fue la unión patriótica Y por
qué eliminarla era el año 1982 Belisario
betancourum político conservador ganó
las elecciones en Colombia en su
discurso prometía que su prioridad era
la paz inició conversaciones con
distintos grupos armados entre ellos la
otrora guerrilla más grande de América
Latina las fuerzas armadas
revolucionarias de Colombia
su capital era la Uribe en el occidental
departamento del meta y allí firmaron
unos acuerdos de paz en 1984
de esos acuerdos un año después nacería
en la unión patriótica a ese partido se
unieron los guerrilleros desmovilizados
una transición de las armas a la
política al partido también llegaron
comunistas sectores sociales e incluso
miembros liberales y conservadores un
espacio transversal para liderar cambios
sociales en Colombia cuenta más a las 24
y melda daza sobreviviente y exiliada
durante más de 20 años en Suecia que
tiene gran acogida porque el ambiente en
la izquierda era de mucho activismo
político de hecho había tres movimientos
cívicos muy importantes uno en pasto
otro en barrancabermeja y el otro en
valledupar se vivían cierta Euforia por
la lucha cívica ciudadana
en 1986 la unión patriótica participó
por primera vez en unas elecciones desde
los años 50 Colombia vivía un
bipartidismo entre liberales y
conservadores y el partido consiguió los
mejores resultados de la historia de la
izquierda convirtiéndose en la tercera
fuerza más votada y una alternativa a
los poderes tradicionales en paralelo
más de 300 militantes Ya habían sido
asesinados
muertes que significarían el final del
acuerdo de paz entre el estado y la
guerrilla de las FARC una fecha que
marcó la historia de Colombia fue el 30
de agosto de 1966 Leonardo posado un
maestro escogido como representante fue
asesinado en menos de 24 horas también
mataban a Pedro Nel Jiménez senador
después de dejar a su hija en el colegio
son los primeros cargos electos de la
unión patriótica a los que se les trunca
la vida Esto hace que meses después dos
congresistas desmovilizados Braulio
Herrera e Iván Márquez abandonen la
actividad política y vuelvan a la lucha
armada de las FARC
pese al llamado de la guerrilla del
regreso al monte de sus militantes la
unión patriótica decidió continuar con
su actividad pero con una nueva fase en
la que el partido fue señalado por el
estado como el brazo político de las
FARC un estigma que provocó que su
Exterminio creciese Pues el año 1988 fue
en el que más asesinatos se produjeron
contra miembros y representantes de la
up cuando percibimos nosotros el
fenómeno justamente después del
resultado electoral nuestros concejales
empiezan a desempeñarse los consejos
municipales y empiezan a asesinarlos en
1988 fue asesinado el candidato
presidencial Jaime pardoleal quien había
obtenido un resultado histórico en los
comicios previos su sucesor como
candidato fue Bernardo Jaramillo ossa
Quién sería asesinado meses antes de las
elecciones presidenciales de 1990 horas
antes de su muerte el ministro de
gobierno Carlos Lemos había dicho que la
upep era el brazo político de las FARC a
lo que jaramillosa respondió que esa
comparación era como colgarle una lápida
del cuello
[Música]
en cada elección la unión patriótico
perdía cargos populares militantes y
votos muchos seguían en la lucha pero
otros para evitar la muerte escogían
entre el exilio o el ingreso a las FARC
los cambios que buscaba impulsar la upe
retaban a los caciques tradicionales
regionales del partido liberal y del
conservador que en muchos casos se
beneficiaban de los negocios del
narcotráfico y tenían relaciones con
Pablo Escobar por otro lado el ejército
colombiano se basaba en la doctrina de
defensa y seguridad anticomunista esto
unió al estado con paramilitares
narcotraficantes y fuerzas armadas que
compartían un enemigo la izquierda así
hablaba en 1997 Jaime Caicedo uno de los
fundadores del partido
sectores reaccionarios de grupos
paramilitares No es cierto
desde luego que nosotros sabemos muy
bien cómo son las conexiones de estos
grupos con con y con la propios sectores
de la inteligencia militar el genocidio
contra la unión patriótica no cesó hasta
el año 2002 aquel año el Consejo
Nacional electoral le retiró la
personería jurídica como partido
político argumentando su poca relevancia
electoral esta decisión fue vista de
negacionista Pues esa pérdida de peso
fue en gran medida por su Exterminio que
nunca le permitió competir con el resto
de partidos en igualdad de condiciones
por este motivo se la restauró la
personería en 2013 Y actualmente forman
parte de la coalición gobernante pacto
histórico con la elección como
presidente de Gustavo Petro y como
vicepresidenta de Francia Márquez la
izquierda llegó por primera vez al poder
un resultado histórico después de
décadas sangrientas en las que la
izquierda vio reducidas las
posibilidades de participar de forma
plena en política por un Exterminio que
en el caso de la unión patriótica la
Corte Interamericana de Derechos Humanos
responsabiliza al Estado de Colombia con
esto concluimos Gracias por compartir y
comentar esas historias que las
encuentran en los programas de France
24.com
[Música]